ça passe quand par elle pour approche
historique ah ok tonique se poursuivit
jusqu'au diago 79 vous avez traversé
l'année 2002 sans l'homme dans pour elle
et le taux de dérive chronométrique de 0
5 sur l'échelle d'aspect bien compris
vaste à bord elle a auteur du 20e siècle
le programme les matrices de régression
sur les courtes périodes attention temps
x vous êtes en phase d'émersion
historique intentions du rib a vu les
turbulences
50 et synchroniser votre pénétration en
1970 d'attention
1980-1981 contact point x 2 juin 1979 et
voilà à mi temps et ce grâce à la chrono
vision vous avez pu suivre pour la
première fois en direct la régression
temporel qui nous permet chaque semaine
de franchir les siècles de futurs et de
vous rejoindre 1979 en 1979 hélas le
voyage dans le temps que nous venons de
faire n'était encore qu'un thème de
science fiction et pourtant en ce moment
même aux environs de paris une
expérience sans précédent est en train
de se dérouler et elle pose pour poules
pour la première fois en termes
scientifiques
la notion de déplacement temporel nous
aurons l'occasion de reparler tout à
l'heure en détail avec le physicien
théoricien et professeurs vigier
le temps est relatif dit on depuis
einstein c'est peut-être vrai puisque
pour vous dix minutes à peine sous des
coulées depuis que je vous ai quitté
tout à l'heure alors que pour moi quinze
jours entiers ont passé quinze jours
durant lesquels j'ai pu aller en
angleterre en 1880 lieu à londres
rencontré l'écrivain de science-fiction
herbert george wells d'ailleurs vous
dire que c'est lui qui m'a donné cette
magnifique cap en souvenir alors je lui
ai suggéré juste avant de lui dire au
revoir décrire une machine l'histoire de
machine à voyager dans le temps et il
m'a promis de le faire et ce livre est
paru en 1896 sous le titre la machine à
explorer le temps et bien c'est à mon
tour que je vous dois vous dire que
temps x est donc à l'origine du thème le
plus riche de toute la science fiction
un thème que nous allons maintenant
explorer ensemble nous allons tant
d'autres
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ah si seulement je pouvais recommencer
si je pouvais revenir marié
et oui lequel d'entre nous n'a pas eu à
un moment ou un autre le désir de
revenir dans le passé et on pour
corriger un événement malheureux ou tout
simplement pour retrouver le temps à
jamais perdu de son enfance
[Musique]
hélas
rien à faire loin de suspendre son vol
le temps passe il coule il fuit en
manque on le trouve long on en prend on
en donne mais tout cela sans jamais
pouvoir agir sur lui et sans savoir ce
qu'il est vraiment
bien sûr nous savons tous nous servir
d'une montre cela veut dire qu'il nous
est possible de mesurer le temps de le
découper en tranches plus ou moins
longue qui vont du millionième de
seconde au millénaire
mais à voir le notre grand rêve à tous
ce n'est pas seulement de mesurer le
temps ce serait de nous entendre m c'est
à dire de pouvoir nous y déplacer à
notre guise dans le futur comme dans le
passé et c'est ce rêve que les auteurs
de science-fiction ans rendu célèbre
sous la forme fameuse du voyage dans le
temps une machine à voyager dans le
temps ce serait l'idéal
il suffirait alors de pousser un levier
comme le fils célèbre voyageur imaginé
par wells en 1898 la machine à voyager
dans le temps pour accélérer ou ralentir
le cours du temps et se déplacer ainsi
dans la quatrième dimension comme au
long d'une route
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors wells c'est la science fiction
mais savez vous qu'un astronome et
ingénieurs français du nom d'emile
drouet a conçu en 1945 une authentique
machine à voyager dans le temps faute de
crédits hélas il n'a jamais pu la
réaliser
aurait-elle marché
tant qu'on va dans le futur en principe
pas de problème après tout le voyageur
de wells peut très bien s'établir en
l'an 800 2701 dans le futur sans
entraîner le moindre paradoxe il ne
perturbe pas l'histoire en revanche
quand le voyageur se rend dans le passé
tout se complique en effet sa seule
présence physique dans le passé perturbe
l'histoire et entraîne ce qu'on appelle
des paradoxes temporels
imaginez par exemple que je construise
une machine à brûler dans le temps et
que je me rende dans le passé afin
d'empêcher le mariage de mes parents
alors dans ce cas il n'a pas pu naître
logiquement si je ne suis pas né je n'ai
donc pas pu constater machine et varié
dans le temps ni remonter dans le passé
afin d'empêcher le mariage de mes
parents
mais bien sûr il est né alors ici je
suis né j'ai effectivement plus
construit ma machine remonter dans le
temps et empêcher le mariage de mes
parents et ainsi de suite le paradoxe
étant insoluble
celui qui va dans le passé et donc
chargé de ce pouvoir exorbitant de
changer l'histoire
toujours avec ma machine si je remontais
deux siècles en arrière pour détourner
d'un polluant premier de sa carrière
militaire et dans ce cas c'est c'est
toute l'histoire de l'europe qu'elle eût
été changée et le rencontrer ainsi dans
la science fiction
d'étranges d'univers où l'on se serre la
main gauche au lieu de la droite où la
machine à vapeur triomphé du moteur à
explosion et ou en 1945 les forces de l'
axe ont remporté la victoire sur les
aligner ses univers s'appelle des
univers parallèles
et c'est pour maintenir l'histoire dans
le court de son lit pour empêcher de
tels bouleversements que des auteurs
comme isaac asimov mais surtout paul
anderson ont créé des patrouilles du
temps dont le rôle consiste à sillonner
les pistes du tentes dans le passé dans
le futur ceci afin d'empêcher des
bouleversements
le voyage dans le temps les univers
parallèles tous là où on le pourrait
encore bien incertain pour admettre de
telles possibilités il faudra sans doute
que l'esprit humain connaissent une
évolution au terme de laquelle nous
aurons une vision une appréhension toute
différente des concept d'espacé de temps
alors comme a osé l'écrire en 1970 le
physicien anglais john barnard il nous
sera peut-être aussi facile de voyager
dans le temps que dans l'espace
ce n'est pas pour aujourd'hui mais
précisément nous avons le temps dans un
million d'années peut-être vous dans 10
millions peu importe contentons-nous
pour l'instant de voyager vers l'avenir
à la vitesse de 60 minutes à l'heure et
puis si nous voulons franchir des
millénaires et bien il n'en sera
toujours la science fiction
[Applaudissements]
la film de jean-claude halliez illustré
par la machine à explorer le temps de
george pal alors professeur vigier merci
d'être avec nous dans le temps x vous
êtes ici donc en qualité de physiciens
théoriciens alors je crois que dans la
réalité la physique théorique les choses
ne se passent pas aussi facilement que
dans le film que nous venons de voir
mais on peut dire que dans la conception
de l'univers machine défendue par la
place et einstein le temps est
rigoureusement fléché du passé vers
l'avenir de sorte que toute régression
ouvert le feu vers le passé est
impossible en revanche revanche le
voyage vers le futur lui est possible
enfin c'est pas tout à fait exact c'est
à dire que la physique moderne permet de
voir dans le passé au travers des par
exemple avec un télescope et galaxies
que je vois la lumière est parti il ya
des millions d'années donc je vois dans
le passé je ne peux pas y aller deuxième
chose est ce que je peux aller dans le
futur alors là en principe la nativité
le permet mais d'une manière compliquée
c'est à dire que comme la temps s'écoule
différemment suivant la vitesse de 2 du
support d'une horloge donnés je peux
partir d'un point est arrivé à un autre
point de l'espace top par deux chemins
différents à des vitesses différentes
et à ce moment là l'âge des deux
voyageurs qui se parent temps semble et
se retrouve à la fin de ceux de ces deux
mouvements est différent en somme c'est
un voyage à sens unique les n'est pas
question de voyage est une question de
voyages et jerez alors en revanche il
existe dont j'avais parlé tout à l'heure
une expérience de physique aujourd'hui
qui est en train de se dérouler et elle
est de nature s'il réussi à bouleverser
totalement notre appréhension du temps
oui plus exactement 2 elle touche au
problème fondamental de la causalité
c'est à dire que pour la place et hunt
stein la lune univers où nous vivons est
une machine vous me donnez toutes les
positions et toutes les vitesses des
particules qui constituent l'univers et
avec les lois de la physique si je les
connais complètement je peux prédire
l'évolution ultérieure de la matière et
le temps est comme un fleuve ou n'entre
jamais deux fois en traversant en étant
portée par lui en quelque sorte alors
dont sheila dans la théorie d'einstein
aucune vitesse ne peut être supérieure à
la vitesse de la lumière ce signifie en
clair 3000 kilomètres par seconde ça
signifie en clair que tous les
évènements passés qui m'influence sont
dans ce qu'on appelle le cône passé de
lumière tous les événements que je peux
influencer son dans le cône du futur et
je ne peux pas influencer ce qu'on
appelle lier c'est-à-dire deux points
qui seraient joints à une vitesse
supérieure à la vitesse de la nouvelle
expérience d'aspect justement elle
touche ça elle touche à ça et c'est pour
ça qu'il s'agit d'une expérience
cruciale elle a été proposée par
einstein en 1935 et en a mis 40 ans a
disposé de la technique nécessaire pour
les réaliser elle est en voie de
réalisation à l'institut d'optique à
orsay alors le principe est tout à fait
simple je fais partie à partir de grains
de lumière en sens opposé d'une même
source est ce ici et ils sont ces deux
grains de lumière sont passés au travers
de deux filtres et sont détectés p1 et
p2 ils sont détectés en d1 et d2 et je
mesure les coïncidences maintenant je
peux installer ici deux aiguillages a1
et a2 qui font qu'ils choisissent ici
entre deux trajectoires différentes
après que les deux photons son parti
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que si j'observe encore pour les
coïncidences prédite par la théorie des
quanta et bien les deux polariseur on
interagit à une vitesse supérieure à la
vitesse de la lumière ce qui détruit la
causalité d'einstein et donc de façon
d'interpréter l'expérience on peut dire
dans un premier cas que le principe de
causalité est donc ruiner ce qui veut
dire que le passé le présent et le futur
sont simultanés oui assez ce que disent
un certain nombre de physiciens
américains
un français qui s'appelle costa de
beauregard je dessine ici la même
expérience symboliquement voilà l'espace
et dans le temps le voilà ma source mais
de grains de lumière partent à la
vitesse de la lumière le long du cône de
lumière et voilà mes deux polariseur
alors deux possibilités première
interprétation possible je peux
télégraphié dans le passé à l'aide de
potentiel avancées qui sont une
possibilité théorique influencer le
passé et ré influencer l'avenir ce qui
explique qu'il ya une interaction comme
ceci naturellement ça suppose
l'existence simultanée du passé du
présent et du futur que notre conscience
en quelque sorte balaÿ gré mais où je
que je pourrai modifié il n'ya plus
l'univers n'est plus une machine est bon
tout là tout l'édifice de la physique
matérialiste s'écoule dans ce cas
pourrait s'ériger on peut donc se
déplacer dans le temps un petit peu
comme le voyageur doit elle jouer mais
je n'y crois absolument pas c'est à dire
que einstein non plus maintenant c'est à
dire que on peut par contre imaginer un
chemin direct de paix 1 ap 2 elle nous
était supérieure à la vitesse de la
lumière seulement ça n'est pas le
mouvement de matière c'est comme le
mouvement d'une onde sur un ko c'est à
dire qu'un physicien qui s'appelle
d'irak est revenu à la vieille image du
philosophe grec héraclite on dit que le
vide est un énorme chaos is up qu'on ne
peut pas voir pas plus que je ne peux
voir l'agitation des molécules de ce
studio par contre les ondes sonores qui
parle de ma bouche et qui arrive à votre
rail ne charrie pas de matière se sont
dévoués comme une danse organisé des
molécules de l'air alors dans ce cas là
on rétablit évidemment le fonctionnement
de la causalité et on maintient le
l'univers machine de la place et
d'einstein merci professeur viger nous
verrons si la physique à travers cette
expérience se donne raison pas aux
auteurs de science-fiction et pour tous
ceux qui veulent malgré tout dès
aujourd'hui voyager dans le temps et
bien je propose tout de suite comme
d'habitude deux ouvrages le premier
c'est la grande anthologie du livre de
poche histoire de voyage dans le temps
une anthologie préparez proposée par
jacques goimard et d'autre part ce livre
dont je vous ai parlé tout à l'heure un
grand classique de la science-fiction
paru en 1896 le premier dans le genre il
s'agit de la machine à explorer le temps
d'herbert george wells alors lisez le
attentivement et vous y verrez bien sûr
entre les lignes qu'il est question de
temps x
chantal nous allons faire un petit
voyage dans le temps une semaine dans le
passé et considérer les normes courrier
qui nous est parvenue cette semaine qu
est ce que tu en as retenu et bien tout
d'abord vous avez été nombreux à nous
envoyer des questionnaires sur les ovnis
alors notamment aussi une école de
longwy qui n'a pas mentionné son adresse
alors je réponds en direct et je vous
donne les coordonnées d'une des
principales fédérations qui s'occupe de
ce phénomène alors pour tous
renseignements écrivez au geipan 18
avenue edouard belin
31000 toulouse
et puis pour rester dans un domaine
voisin je vous signale que mercredi 6
juin sur tf1 à 22 heures vous pourrez
suivre dans la série à la poursuite des
étoiles une émission de robert clark et
nicholas trotsky qui traitera de
l'histoire de l'univers elle fera le
point sur les hypothèses actuellement
discutée sur l'origine de notre univers
sur les moyens utilisés par les
astronomes pour déterminer si cet
univers est fini ou infini enfin bref en
général toutes ces caractéristiques
et puis enfin notre concours notre
concours l'être à l'avenir auquel vous
avez déjà être très nombreux à
participer cette semaine je rappelle
pour les autres vous avez jusqu'au 15
juin pour nous envoyer votre vision de
l'avenir dans 100 ans les deux lettres
les plus intéressantes seront publiés
dans le magazine fiction l'enfant en
général vous aurez des abonnements des
oeuvres complètes et de nombreux lots
alors je vous souhaite bonne chance je
vous rappelle notre adresse temps x tf1
17 rue de l'arrivée pièce 4071 75015
paris
voilà le contact avec votre époque 1979
s'achève nous avons dans quelques
instants repartir vers une autre époque
et avant cela imaginez un instant que à
cette époque là nous rencontrions le
jeune napoléon bonaparte et que nous
l'empêcherons de devenir en prêt c'est
tout un autre monde qui en aurait
résulté un monde parallèle au nôtre ce
sont ces mondes parallèles que nous vous
invitons à explorer la semaine prochaine
avec nous ici là sachez tout simplement
que l'avenir c'est tout ce que vous
pouvez changer je vous souhaite une
bonne semaine à trappes
[Musique]